[Music]
hurricane Irma is still leaving
businesses flat in the Florida Keys
three months after the storm hit the
state the keys attract more than three
million tourists a year accounting for
more than half of the islands economy
tourism brings in nearly three billion
dollars a year
one local official says Burma jeopardize
three hundred million dollars in revenue
Omar Villafranca went to Islamorada
Florida to see the plan to survive the
vacation slump
Omar good morning good morning the busy
tourist season here in the Keys starts
the day after Christmas and there are
plenty of things to do
of course fishing and diving or just
feeding the tarpon but the challenge
here in ila Mirada is actually finding a
place to stay many of the big resorts
remain closed after being battered by
hurricane
[Music]
sometimes it can be easy to forget
Irma was ever here but the giveaway at
this waterfront restaurant in La Mirada
is the empty chairs how important is
tourism to this area tourism that is the
lifeblood of Florida case
Andy Newman is communications director
of the Florida Keys and Key West Tourism
Council tourism accounts for 60% of the
keys overall economy and more than half
of the islands jobs we're down about 28%
and available hotel rooms well you know
if we don't have hotel rooms then how
can you possibly be up or as busy if
there's not enough hotel space what
happens to the restaurants what happens
to the bars
obviously it impacts everybody the
problem is most severe in ila Mirada
where nearly seventy percent of the
hotel rooms are out of order councilman
and restaurant owner Mike Forester is
feeling that impact you can't stay here
but you could play here with fewer heads
and beds that translates into fewer
hungry mouths to feed at Mike's
restaurant his business is down 50%
everything we have here is available
it's ready to go all the merchants are
ready the businesses are open but we're
dismissing bedrooms ila Mirada is this
self proclaimed sport fishing capital of
the world the fish are still biting but
Steve Leopold can't hook any customers
on his charter boat how busy are you
usually between the holidays we're
booked every day we fish every day and
sometimes multiple trips per day but
this year we have zero in September the
category four hurricane slammed into the
keys with 130 mile per hour winds
destroying more than 1,100 homes and
leaving behind 500 million dollars in
damages
resorts have been racing to finish
repairs in time for the winter season
but some properties will be closed until
next fall we're gonna be fine
Don Zinner owns the lookout Lodge a 10
bedroom boutique hotel that reopened
quickly after suffering only minimal
damage you don't have a lot of
competition right now
not particularly not four rooms now but
do you want that competition absolutely
you first have to make sure that you've
got a place to stay
Morton Harriette Cohen from California
have been visiting the keys for 15 years
once you get a place to stay the
restaurants are open the weather is
beautiful it is the Florida Keys some
resorts are using this time to remodel
their properties but some small business
owners we talked with said it may take a
full year to recover their losses for
CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca ila Murata Florida a
big hit for that state they will be best
o recovering